big story of course is Joe Biden that's
the big story in the Democratic primary
Joe Biden has opened up a twenty four
point lead over the nearest candidate
twenty four point lead yeah
analysts expect that lead to fade once
Biden starts talking you know saying his
wife is now getting into the picture
today Joe Biden's wife Jill acknowledged
it many times in her life many times men
have touched her inappropriately
she said that yeah Jill said I learned
to deal with it by saying things like
knock it off or okay Joe I'll marry you
[Applause]
uh-huh
better O'Rourke my sanity ever know I
know it's Beto Beto this hope but I
always want to say Beto know it's what I
really want to say is - - Beto O'Rourke
said if we don't deal with climate
change we only have 10 more years on
earth yeah yeah and response Bernie
Sanders said I'd love 10 more years on
earth it's not sophisticated but that is
my take on very soon I don't think he's
ever done that once no but I do it in
people at home know what I'm talking
about Democratic presidential candidate
Eric's wawel is still paying off student
loans yeah when he heard that Donald
Trump said there's a porn star named
student loans
[Applause]